former presidential candidate grilled by
a famous rapper exactly this is really
cool so senator Bernie Sanders a teamed
up with guess who cardi B for a lot of
Instagram interview the outspoken
supporter of Sanders had a Instagram
live yesterday and she sat down with
Bernie Sanders and had some really
interesting things to say about why
senator Sanders suspended his campaign
and more importantly she talked about
why now he's backing Joe Biden and so is
she take a listen to this so now we have
45 and Joe Biden and you know me since
I've been so on you and so focus on you
I haven't really done my research well
on Joe Biden I won't want you to throw
my platform why who endorsed him Donald
Trump is to my mind the most dangerous
president in the modern history of
America what I am also trying to do
right now Claudia
is to work with Joe to see that he
becomes a more progressive candidate so
geillis is really important because a
lot of people were worried that some of
senator Sanders supporters would not
back Joe Biden
well somebody like cardi B says she is
listen flat I think cardi B and Bernie
Sanders are a show waiting to happen the
two of them clearly have a rapport